so the other day i was at breakfast and
this girl sits down with her with a guy
i definitely was not her boyfriend
because he knew absolutely nothing about
her and if he did she was sure to inform
him pretty much every little
detail it was pretty obvious too to me
and probably everybody else around her
because she was talking so extremely
loud that i wanted to give her a little
puppy muzzle and say shut your mouth can
you let him have a word in do you even
know his name probably not this was a
early morning she looked a little rough
he looked a little rough pretty sure you
guys just met the bar the night before
or
yeah she starts talking about everything
about the most mundane ridiculous things
about her life and i just kind of take a
little glance over
after 20 minutes this guy has said
nothing does he want to say something i
have no idea because she's never even
given him a second to say anything you
will never believe this i'll just
started getting half sizes in their
shoes but you know what's crazy i'm not
even half size but that's myself oh my
god guess what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
live crazy today and i'm gonna get a
half size shoot it all though i'm just
like girl shut your mouth pretty
confident that uh this relationship or
whatever it is is not gonna work because
as much as you
whether you're a guy or a girl a
relationship is a two-way street one way
two-way you have conversations he has
conversations if you're not having a
conversation back and forth just it's
not gonna work so as much as you want
that relationship to be about you it's
not
i'm sure you guys know a person like
this if you do feel free to leave me a
comment below and let me know your
stories with that person you think this
video's about you about you so sitting
here raining about this girl and i
remembered this julian smith video that
i watched a little while ago because
this video
truly captures the essence of these
people i love you guys be sure to
subscribe so you'll see when i uh post a
new video here and please please please
go watch this julian smith video it's
just classic all right bye